the opening scene begins with a young
woman Michelle who is hastily packing
her belongings after having one last
argument with her boyfriend Ben over the
phone she storms out leaving her keys
and a diamond ring behind she drives out
of the city plagued with troubles in her
mind a short while later she pulls over
at a gas station to refill her tank
during this a suspicious truck parks
behind Michelle's car but she doesn't
pay much attention to it and continues
on her journey while driving through
rural Louisiana at night she receives a
call from Ben pleading with her to come
back however Michelle doesn't speak a
word and hangs up the call abruptly in
order to divert her mind she turns on
her car radio and hears the news reports
of a power surge that caused widespread
blackouts in several major cities not
long after Ben calls her again diverting
her attention from the road for a second
as a result her car gets slammed by a
truck causing it to flip off the road
and rendering her unconscious later
Michelle regains her Consciousness and
finds herself in a concrete room with a
wound on her head and her hand hooked to
a saine drip furthermore her leg is also
injured and is chained to a wall which
freaks her out she frantically attempts
to pry the shackles off but to no avail
she then makes another effort she uses
her saline drip Pole to pull her phone
from the opposite corner of the room she
successfully retrieves it but there's no
signal in the room just then she hears
someone unlocking the door from outside
a man named Howard enters the room with
a plate full of food and a gun on his
belt Michelle begs for her life but the
man claims to have rescued her from the
car accident and is intending to keep
her alive the only person I got a
problem with is [__] Donnie he also
gives her a set of crutches telling her
to practice walking with them after this
he tosses a key to the chains and walks
out Michelle gets up using the crutches
and puts on her clothes she tries to
open the door but it's locked determined
to escape she starts carving Ving the
tip of one of the crutches and sharpens
it into a weapon with the intention of
attacking Howard she then lights a fire
which triggers the fire alarm prompting
Howard to return as soon as the man
walks in she tries to stab him with her
makeshift weapon but her effort proves
futile as Howard quickly grabs and
sedates her when Michelle wakes up after
a while Howard calmly explains that
there has been a massive nuclear attack
perhaps launched by Russians or martians
which has made the air unbreathable as a
result he brought her down to the bunker
beneath his farm where he has made all
the necessary arrangements for survival
he further asserts that they can't leave
the place for the next few years because
of the poisoned air Michelle wants to
call her family to inform them that
she's okay but Howard is sure that
everyone outside is dead their
conversation is suddenly interrupted by
some sounds indicating that someone else
is outside Howard once again locks her
inside before going to deal with the
other person a few hours later Mich
Melle wakes up to find the door open she
curiously walks out of the room and sees
the hallway full of supplies she also
meets another Resident who introduces
himself as EMT Michelle tries to
persuade him to escape together but the
latter is also convinced that the air
outside is contaminated just then Howard
shows up and gives Michelle a tour of
his well stocked bunker containing DVDs
books and other entertainment following
this he leads her to his private room
with an attached bathroom allowing her
to use it Michelle demands some privacy
but he tells her to simply pull the
curtains as he doesn't trust her ah the
old PE curtain Kink seeing her doubtful
face Howard takes her to the airlock and
shows her his two decayed pigs outside
as evidence of the Fallout during this
time Michelle spots Howard's truck on
the side and recognize it as the same
one that hit her growing her suspicion
later on she has a one-to-one
conversation with EMT who shares some
information about Howard turns out that
he worked on satellites for the military
before moving to the farm he always
talked about imminent disaster due to
which he started building this bunker
Michelle asserts that Howard
purposefully crashed her car to kidnap
her but EMT doesn't believe this he
claims to have seen the attack happen
describing it as a red flash knowing
that Howard's theories about the
apocalypse were coming true EMT fought
his way into the bunker to survive
injuring his arm in the process their
conversation is abruptly interrupted by
Howard who invites them for dinner
Michelle is uneasy at the dining table
wondering if Howard heard what she said
however when EMT starts a casual
conversation she feels relaxed the two
then talk about various topics which
gradually starts to annoy Howard when he
reaches his breaking point he shouts at
them saying he wants to eat peacefully
seeing how Howard is easily annoyed
Michelle comes up with an idea she then
begins to flirt with EMT and even
touches his hand while talking fueled by
jealousy and rage Howard slams the table
and Corners her instructing her to
behave no talking no touching only
tinkling Michelle uses this opportunity
to steal a bunch of keys from his side
pocket and hide them in her hand after
waiting for the right moment she smashes
a beer bottle over Howard's head and
makes her way to the exit door she
manages to unlock the first door just
before Howard catches her as she
proceeds to unlock the outermost door
she spots a car outside and yells for
help Howard screams at her asking her
not to open that door but she ignores
him and continues trying the keys all of
a sudden a distressed middle-aged woman
named Leslie appears outside she is
covered in lesions and begs to be let in
Howard urges Michelle not to let the
woman in because doing so will kill them
all this leaves her confused and she
doesn't know what to do just then Leslie
starts banging her head on the door and
ultimately succumbs to her infection
fearing that Howard might be right
Michelle stops unlocking the door and
Retreats in the aftermath Howard Howard
approaches Michelle in her concrete room
and confesses that he accidentally
struck her car that day he reveals that
he had heard the news about the
apocalypse which caused him to race back
home in a panic during this the accident
happened which made him feel so guilty
that he couldn't abandon her there this
finally convinces Michelle and she
starts listening to him she also helps
him stitch up his forehead wound she
caused earlier the two then start
conversing and he opens up about his
daughter Megan who is taken to Chicago
by her mother later that night Michelle
and EMT have a brief conversation with
both of them sharing their personal
stories EMT tells her about how he
competed in track competitions and got
accepted to Louisiana Tech University
however he got scared of failing and
didn't go in turn Michelle recounts a
time when she saw a little girl being
abused by her dad at a hardware store
despite this she wasn't able to take
action especially considering her own
Troublesome childhood she regrets her
decision but EMT assures her that their
lives can still mean something since
since they're still alive over the next
several days the trio becomes adjusted
to underground life and starts working
together like a real family one day the
air filtration system is blocked after
something loud passes overhead Michelle
being the smallest in size is assigned
to crawl through the vents to the
control room and restart the air
filtration system despite being
initially nervous she somehow manages to
make it to the control room and
reactivates the system successfully but
before returning back she notices a
ladder leading to a padlocked skylight
with help scratched from the inside
furthermore she finds a bloody earring
which she recognizes from the picture of
Megan later Michelle shares her
Discovery with EMT and shows him a
picture of Megan the latter recognizes
her as a local girl named Britney who
went missing 2 years ago this makes them
suspect that Howard is a threat so they
decide to make their way out of the
bunker for this they need protective
gear so Michelle plans to construct a
makeshift hazmat suit from this point
onwards the duo steal Howard's tools and
start working on their plan one day
Howard summons Michelle and EMT to
transfer a barrel out of a kitchen shelf
he then reveals its content to be
perchloric acid that dissolves most
biological material including humans
following this Howard starts
interrogating about his tools
threatening to immerse them both in acid
try me I'll melt you in a brave move EMT
takes the blame claiming that he was
trying to make a weapon he says that he
wanted Michelle to respect him the way
she respects Howard he then apologizes
for everything but Howard responds by
gunning him down without any hesitation
Howard is just misunderstood afterwards
Michelle is sitting alone in her room
looking at emt's ID card and mourning
his loss not wanting his sacrifice to go
in vain she continues working on the
Hazmat suit while Howard is busy
disposing of the body sometime later she
hears his footsteps and hastily hides
her work but he manages to Spot It under
the mattress making him Furious and it's
not CGI John Goodman's veins are all
natural sensing the imminent threat she
runs out of the room locking him inside
she enters Howard's room and starts
searching for any useful tools soon
after she finds a chemical coolant but
Howard catches up to her she then kicks
the barrel of acid towards him causing
him to Tumble down and fall face first
onto it as he screams in
pain Michelle jumps over to her room
grabs the Hazmat suit and makes her
towards the exit the disfigured Howard
intercepts her but she brings down a
shelf to stop him and climbs over it to
escape however her way is again blocked
by fire caused due to a short circuit in
a quick action she climbs to the air
vent and crawls her way to the control
room dodging several of his knife
attacks in the process stabby stab stab
stabby stab once there Michelle Dons her
suit and climbs the ladder to the
Skylight exit she freezes the padlock
with the chemical coolant and breaks it
open finally making making her way out
of the bunker she then looks around for
any sign of life but finds the entire
vicinity calm perplexed she gets into
Howard's truck to drive away but
accidentally rips her suit in the
process fearing that she will get
poisoned she frantically wraps up the
torn spot with duct tape just then she
sees birds flying overhead which makes
her realize that the air isn't
contaminated she slowly takes off her
mask and breathes in the air but nothing
happens this prompts her to finally
breathe a sigh of relief she then stands
on top of Howard's truck to view her
surroundings and spots an aircraft at
the same time the bunker explodes which
attracts the aircraft as it comes nearby
Michelle realizes that it's actually a
massive biomechanical alien hovercraft
or an Maba panicked she hastily tries to
drive away but she can't find Keys she
then runs to Leslie's car but
accidentally triggers its alarm sensing
the potential danger she runs inside a
shed where she finds Leslie dead body
Michelle somehow maintains her composure
and peeps through a hole only to witness
a quadrupedal creature lifting the car
it slowly approaches the shed freaking
her out Michelle then hurriedly
retrieves the car keys from Leslie's
body and turns the alarm on diverting
the creature's attention back to it
following this she makes a run towards a
nearby Farmhouse with the creature
chasing after her as she approaches the
house the alien aircraft emerges out of
nowhere it slowly Rises and moves
towards Michelle spreading a toxic green
gas in the air seeing this she rushes
back to the truck retrieves her mask and
puts it on in the neck of time but soon
after the alien Craft's tentacles lift
up the entire truck and bring it closer
to its mouth to engulf it amidst this
intense moment Michelle finds a lighter
and a liquor bottle inside the car
giving her an idea she then creates a
Molotov cocktail and seizes the
opportunity to throw it into the
creature's mouth as it explodes it drops
the truck to the ground but thank
thankfully Michelle is fine following
this she gets into Leslie's car and
drives down the road knocking off
Howard's mailbox with the address 10
Cloverfield Lane that's the name of the
movie baby on the way Michelle turns on
the radio broadcast in which the
announcer says that anybody seeking
Refuge from the alien attacks may head
to Baton Rouge but anybody with combat
or medical expertise is needed in
Houston after a while of deliberation
Michelle heads to Houston while a larger
alien craft is revealed silhouetted by
lightning subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching